unable to control protesters from the
mostly Hindu Mayte majority Gather in
the Indian Capital to make their voices
heard
we are suffering because of their lies
the lies she's referring to is the
allegation by the mostly Christian
cookie tribal group in Manipur state
that they are victims of ethnic
cleansing at the hands of the Mayte
these mate demonstrators have several
demands
foreign
[Applause]
to this the spokesperson for a kooky
Civil Society organization says it's a
malicious label being used against them
when they say cookie Norco terrorists or
you know other other connotations when
they give to this till today be it the
kokomi be the state government they
haven't come up with anything to back up
you know these claims that that they're
making so to us it just seems as another
narrative that they wish to push forward
in order to continue to be able to
continue with this agenda of you know
ethnic ethnic cleansing ethnic
discrimination
there's been months of violence sparked
by a Court ruling which recommended that
the government consider including
mayte's as part of India's scheduled
tribes category it would give them
special economic benefits and quotas in
government jobs and education currently
reserved for the kooky people
experts say the state government's
inability to quell the violence has only
created a security vacuum see the
situation demands immediate action
whether it's it's done by the center or
by the state see otherwise this problem
will continue see cookies have lost
total faith in the state machinery and
State Police
many believe the social fabric of many
poor is being stretched to its limits
meanwhile amid the allegations encounter
allegations the list of victims on both
sides continues to grow
at level Al Jazeera